foreign
Sacramento what's up Nicole
hello what's up
so
um I'm really nervous right now so I'm
just trying to get the words to my mind
Hey I've never lost a a a a patient yet
I I don't think so maybe I have they
just haven't called me back but
um okay no I think you're good man and
by the way I'm not good at this either
so same team we're good you'll be you'll
be better at this than me so what's up
so I have been experiencing episodes of
Rage towards my children
um
and I'm just really I'm just scared
that I I don't know how to get under
control it's not like anger it's like
my heart pounds I feel hot my eyes are
popping out of my head I'm screaming
I'm spanking my kids out of anger and
I I just I need help I don't know how to
stop at times
uh where does the rage come from
I just rage means you feel trapped when
did you start feeling trapped
well
a huge responsibility but I chose it and
so I but you that also means you can
unchoose it
yes yes of course okay what else why do
you feel trapped
I just I feel it's exactly what my
parents did to me and I and I feel like
I'm just right back in the cycle of my
family trauma and I'm gonna do the same
thing to my kids
and they're going to have the same
resentment towards me
and I don't know how to get out listen
to me a hundred percent you're right
I wish there was some magic there's you
definitely one thousand percent need to
go talk to somebody okay
yeah
and until you have the courage to do
that you are making the choice you know
what
more than I want to get well and see a
counselor and talk to somebody I want
you guys to be miserable too
okay that's the choice you're making
but bigger than that
I wish there was some more sophisticated
thing that I'm about to tell you but
Nicole stop
you can stop
you might not be at peace you might have
to walk outside the door you might have
to go for a walk around your house and
take five laps but stop
I do not buy for one second that you
can't just you can't just help yourself
it just happens I don't buy it
yeah is that true
no I I completely agree
from this point forward dude I don't
know how to stop sometimes and don't
know how to don't get to the moment
don't get to the moment that's the
problem so earlier on I used an analogy
um earlier today I was in an interview
if you take a two liter bottle a brand
new 2-liter bottle of like Dr Pepper or
Coke and you shake it up
and then you pop the top off that thing
you're trying to catch all that fizz
yeah because that sucker is so packed to
the gills and then they shoot gas in
there to fill it up even tighter
and what you have to do with your life
is to create you have to dump some of
that coke out of that sucker if you have
a two liter bottle of coke and it's only
half filled and you shake it up
when you pop the top on it it will make
the noise it'll go it'll shoot the gas
out and the the the coke will rise but
it won't shoot all over the all over
your table on the floor
because there's not so much built up
pressure in there you see what I'm
saying
oh that's that's how I feel at times I
just feel like it's spilling over
spilling over spill
Ed but that you've got to create margin
in other places of your life so when
your kids act like kids they're
Knuckleheads they're loud they're
emotional they say frustrating things
they try to pee in the bathroom and they
pee all over God's I don't know what
they're I don't know how they're I don't
know like it's just Madness
yeah that you have some capacity to
absorb that
and that might mean and I've talked to a
number of mothers
that might mean that you've got to put
your kids in school for a season to give
yourself some space
yeah and I promise you the end of times
won't come if your kids go to a school
go to a school whether it's a private
school or a public school they have
parents who love them they're gonna be
fine
yeah next year they're going to a
private school okay maybe we need to
excel I think some major changes maybe
we need to accelerate that
I don't want your kids having another
semester of a mom who hates them
I know I know
but you know hate me like I hated my
parents but Nicole you're not caring for
Nicole
do you see what I'm saying
yeah
because Nicole can't do this 24 7 365
and that's okay very very few people can
but when you take care of Nicole you
will say out loud I need these things I
need space between my kids I need to go
get a job
I need to go be with other adults I need
to fill in the blank whatever your needs
are they can be all over the place who
cares they just are
and those needs are going to change they
might be one way this year and they
might be different next year in the
whatever it is and I don't think this is
it's not fair to blame this all on
homeschooling
it's you've created a world where you've
gotten no space
yeah you're trapped both emotionally and
otherwise where's your uh is
is is there do you have a romantic
partner in the mix you have a husband in
the mix my husband how's he
participating in all this
homeschooling and the kids is
mainly on me okay
um
he does his best he's a fantastic dad
but when it comes to their everyday it's
on me okay
have you said the words to him not in
Rage or in anger but in a private
conversation where you're just being
open and vulnerable with each other have
you said the words I can't continue
okay what was his response
to make it better that's that's one of
the most beautiful things I've heard
it's awesome
now it sounds like the only person who's
not letting this thing ride is you
can you have peace to send them back to
school yeah be nervous you know what
someone's gonna make fun of them
someone's gonna be mean so he's gonna
laugh at their clothes someone's gonna
make fun of their hair that's there's
gonna be part of that and that's why
they have parents mom and dad who love
them
right
yeah
anger covers up sadness and points us to
something we can't control
that we wish was different right it
points us to things that we wish were
different
and often anger is our body feeling like
we fail we're failing at something
and it is
and when you grow up with abusive
parents
your body protects itself with a big
thick blanket and we call it a blanket
shame
that's right because nobody would
protect you and they should have
right
yeah
do you want another life
oh I love my life no no no no do you
want a more yeah I asked that the wrong
way do you want a more do you want a
more peaceful way of being
yes and I pray for that constantly okay
for peace and calmness you have to do
different things
what we're doing so far is now working
can we agree on that
okay we gotta do something different
and I don't know what that's going to be
for your life it's going to be any
number of things
it might mean that you sit down with
your husband and you say I have to get
up and go for a long walk by myself in
the morning and listen to my songs I've
got to get up in the morning and
whatever
I've got to have one night a week to
meet with the with the women in my
community whatever the thing is
and I know you commute a long way and we
have to go back and forth I get all that
but I need you here or maybe we need to
move closer to where you work so you
have to commute so far so you can
provide some more help on that like we
got to get radical here because we are
changing a family tree Nicole
and every step along the way is going to
be uncomfortable because you've never
seen it done before and it's going to
feel weird
but it's gonna be right
so hear me say you deserve better than
this and your kids do too so from this
day forward never yell at your kids
again
never hit your kids again ever
and I know you don't want to don't
and start the work go call a counselor
today
hang on the line I'm gonna send you a
copy of own your past change your future
I want you to read it I'll also send you
a link to a free audiobook I want you to
listen to it if that's easier
but you have to acknowledge what
happened to you and you have to decide
I'm the person who's going to turn and
face this forest fire and it's going to
burn me and I'm gonna get scars but this
will not continue with my kids and by
the way tell your kids I'm sorry I
screwed up I shouldn't have yelled at
you
I shouldn't hit you I'm sorry
so sorry
you're gonna go see a counselor then you
and your husband are gonna sit down and
you are going to re reimagine your life
from the moment you wake up to the
moment you go to bed and say okay what
do we have to do to make a different
life for ourselves and our kids
that might mean we have to move that
might mean we got to take different jobs
that might mean kids are going to public
school for the rest of the year and then
before they go to private school
whatever the thing is that might mean
like my kids ain't going to public
school well they are now
because I'm gonna keep them safe and I'm
gonna make sure they're loved and
they're connected
never
hit your kids again
and Nicole
for the first time in your life
putting a coal up at the top of that
list
start loving Nicole like nobody except
your husband and your kids have ever
loved Nicole
and ask her what do you need
to be whole and well so that our kids
can be holding well
you're worth it you're worth it you're
worth it